Hi, my name is Al
and I'm an accessibility tester at Fable.
Um, today the request title is, uh,
record a Goose Sighting,
and the slug is
U-O-C-I-R-G-S two.
Uh, I'm using, um, an Android phone,
which is Samsung Galaxy Node eight.
I'll be using OS magnification
and Chrome is the browser for today.
Um, so the task, uh, for the task, I will,
uh, be answering some questions in a survey on the website,
and I, uh, will try to, uh,
complete the survey and talk about my experience as I,
uh, go through the process.
Uh, so let's get started.
So as, as soon as I clicked on the link, it brought me
to this, uh, website on this page.
And again,
I don't see a lot of stuff here,
so I'll just explore the page first.
So right now I'm un magnified
and now I'll just turn on the magnification.
Uh, for now I can see the big, uh, button, uh,
which says start.
Now. I like the size of the button just as soon
as I open the page
so I can see record a goose siding.
Uh, again, the font is, uh, working for me.
I like the size of it as well,
so I like how I can just pinch and make, uh, a screen bigger
and smaller because sometimes, uh, I'm not able to do that.
And then I have to again, use the hand gesture of
double tapping with, uh, one finger,
and then it, uh, turns on the west magnification.
So as you can see, uh, to read, uh,
the instruction under it, I'll have
to magnify the screen then so I can use the service.
Tell us if you like.
Okay. So it gives me some, um,
some context on, um, how I can use this service.
And then I see the start now,
so quite straightforward till here.
And then I see, uh, information about geese.
And then, oh, this, this is great
because it has links.
Uh, I can see two links here. Reader
Read about ease on Wikipedia
and then visit the RSPM website.
Okay. I like how they have not, they have mentioned
where the, uh, these links will take me.
So before even I click it, I'm aware, uh,
what these links are about.
I'll quickly try to check if these are functional.
Okay, so they're taking me directly to the Wikipedia.
Apologies. Uh, I had to come back, uh,
'cause I had exit exited the testing environment.
Uh, so I was on this, uh, Wikipedia page,
which opened when I clicked on the link
provided on the homepage.
Um, I will try to go back to the homepage.
Okay, so I'm back, uh, at the homepage now,
and I'm assuming, uh, when I click on the other link, uh,
it should, uh, take me to
the RSPD website.
I see a more link here.
Nothing was mentioned here.
Uh, I had thought that maybe it'll tell me what, uh,
maybe some more options
or some more links will, uh, will drop down
and then, um, I'll choose where to,
but it took me to a website.
Uh, so not sure why we kept more
and we didn't, um, specify the name of the page
where I would be taken to.
Okay, so, uh,
now I wanted, uh, I will just click on, uh,
start now and see what comes next.
Okay. So it, uh, brought me to the survey
and I like, uh, the font and the size of the questions.
Uh, the size of the answer options, uh,
is not working that great.
I like how, um, the,
uh, these, um, the,
the place where we choose it is still nice and
Big, but uh, the text is really small,
so if you can make the text bigger here, I think
that would be great.
So it'd say select yes if you like these.
So there are some instructions just under it
for me that, uh, I know these are just some, uh, some
instructions, but the font is really light for me.
And if they are there, then
anyways I would read them, right?
So if they're a little darker, that would be really helpful.
So I clicked yes.
And here I also wanna see if I can, uh,
use it in the landscape mode as well
because it just increases the area, uh,
or it just spreads out the text
for me, which is really helpful.
So yeah, I can use in, in both the portrait
and the landscape mode, which I, which I'm liking.
So the next question, what type of it you see?
And then again, there are some instructions.
Tell us what type of go it was.
And I think that's the placeholder text is it
just gives us a hint.
Yeah, I'm just putting a random, um,
answer
and then I'll continue.
I feel if we have any, a dropdown here, uh, with the names
of the cos, that would be helpful as well.
If a person is not aware, uh, it,
it would really be helpful if we have, um,
maybe names of different
or different species of, of cos we have.
I think that would be helpful too.
Okay, I, uh, clicked on continue
and it brought me to the next question.
What did you see? Uh, when did you see the goose?
And then it saves me, for example, 16.
Okay, so here we have to put the date.
Okay, the form fields are nice and big.
Um, so I, I'll just put a random date
and here I also,
because uh, I feel it's a survey, so I'll just, I'll try
to put, um,
and try to see if, uh,
the instrument can also validate the date I put.
And if I can see any error messages too,
I'll put the month as 13 as doesn't exist.
Yeah, so I didn't see any error message here
or, um, there was no validation of the date.
I think, uh, adding that would be really helpful
if accidentally I just type something wrong.
Having an error message, uh, always, um, helps me,
uh, you know, double check if I type things right.
'cause I'm somebody with low vision,
so I always tend to type wrong.
Okay, so it brought me to, uh, the page where it says,
check your answers, uh, before sending your application.
Okay. I really like it
because it just gives me that, uh, opportunity
to double check what I wrote, uh,
goose details, uh, you like, so it, it
has the question and then it has my answer
and then it has the link to change that as well.
So I would say quite simple and easy to understand.
I could see the change link,
but if we can just make it a little bold, I think
that would be even more helpful
because I have to magnify more
otherwise type of go that you saw.
So I'll just try to add, add it white
or as soon as I typed it, it brought me back to,
to the survey.
So I'll just put black
and I just
chose Sarah.
I had thought that it, maybe I would be able
to change my answer there, uh, just in that space.
But it brought me back to that question in the survey.
And then I have to take the next question again.
I think that's a little inconvenient
three
and I think the same would happen if I tried
to change any of the other options.
And,
And then now send your application.
So I'm just going through, uh, the content under,
uh, now send your application
what happens with my data.
Okay, so I see another link here as well.
Nothing.
Okay, so I clicked on it
and the dialogue box just opened, uh, again, very close
to it, so I didn't miss it.
I liked that and how the, uh, whole link became yellow.
So I just, uh, clicked on it again. Uh, just to close it.
I was not sure 'cause there was not,
I couldn't see a close button to close it,
so I just clicked on that.
I feel if we have a close button, uh, on this,
it would be helpful too.
And then I can just click continue.
Uh,
and it just gave me the message that the goose was recorded.
Okay. So I was able to, uh, complete the task.
Uh, I was able to, uh, to fill in the question, uh,
the answers to the questions
and also change, uh, the op the answer options for some.
Uh, overall I feel it was, it was, um,
the whole process was quite intuitive.
Uh, quite straightforward. The contrasts worked for me.
Uh, the design was simple and easy to understand as well.
Uh, some things which I felt, you know, um,
just based on the, the tech size
or the font size for the options,
if we can make those bigger
because we, we have a lot of whitespace, uh,
that would really help.
Uh, somebody, uh,
who is a plan screen manipulation user like me.
Uh, and also validating, adding that, um,
validation criteria to the dates would help again,
because I tend
or to, to, um, type wrong sometimes.
So it, having that error message show up, uh,
really helps me, uh, double check if I,
uh, typed right.
Uh, but yeah, uh, that was my experience.
Thank you so much for listening to me today.